aber für unwahrscheinlich halten sie
jetzt dieses szenario und ihre waage das
ist ein einen atomwaffen einsatz geben
könnte also vor den kulissen wieder
gesagt das ist alles undenkbar hinter
den kulissen können sie bei manchen
nationen hören ich rede jetzt nicht von
deutschland dass das bereits eingepreist
ist die der die taktisch
natürlich ist aber auch ziemlich schräg
das stimmt also kein großer krieg
sondern eben die frage wie würde putin
damit umgehen wenn er jetzt im don was
richtig in bedrängnis kommt würde er
dann ein zeichen setzen dann gibt es den
einen oder anderen planer der eigentlich
damit rechnet der wunderschön so kleine
szenarien vor augen hat entweder über
über mehr oder gleich auf und bei der
ost ukraine
also so etwas gibt es und bin darüber
nachgedacht wird dann denke ich steht es
uns deutschen auch in europa gut an
darüber auch nachzudenken das heißt aber
nicht gleich hasenfüßig davonzulaufen
nachdenkt dann gebe ich die fahrt direkt
weiter jürgen hardt in der
unionsfraktion wenn sie da in der
fraktion zusammen sitzen und mit
friedrich merz diskutieren der ja einer
der wenigen politiker war der nach kiew
gefahren ist der erste politiker
diskutieren sie da über die frage eines
atom-gaus 30 ich also wir diskutieren in
der fraktion intensiv über die frage und
ich glaube das tun alle
bundestagsfraktionen weil es für uns
auch eine extrem belastende situation
ist wir sind in dieser situation
hineingeraten ohne dass wir dafür etwas
konnten wir machen uns natürlich
vorwürfe dass wir vielleicht das eine
oder andere hätten besser vorhersehen
können aber es bleibt dabei putin ist
aggressor und ich komme mit meiner
fraktion zum ergebnis dass es das beste
für uns alle wäre wenn es der ukraine
gelingen würde putin ein zweites mal
eine blutige nase zu verpassen um es
etwas salopp zu formulieren und den mann
ein zweites mal nach klafft also eine
seine militärische strategie durch zu
durchkreuzen ihn also einen sieg
nicht zu können und das könnte dazu
führen dass putin an einen punkt kommt
wo er selbst einschätzt ist es besser zu
verhandeln auch wenn er vielleicht nicht
alle seine ziele durchsetzen kann als
diesen krieg mit unwägbaren ausgang
fortzusetzen das halte ich für das
wahrscheinlichste szenario ich kann
nicht sagen dass es so kommt aber das
halte ich für das wahrscheinlichste
szenario und deswegen finde ich diese
waffenlieferungen total wichtig und es
wäre für uns alle das beste wenn das so
käme und deutschland und europa sollte
bereit stehen dann auch in einem solchen
verhandlungsprozess zur seite zu stehen
allerdings müssen dafür die waffen
schweigen ich kann ich nicht akzeptieren
dass man verhandelt auf der einen seite
und auf der anderen seite werden
menschen umgebracht ich kann mich
erinnern vor ein bisschen mehr als drei
monaten mittlerweile als ich mich auf
den weg gemacht habe in die ukraine das
war zehn tage ungefähr vor dem krieg
oder 14 tage wir sind in die ost ukraine
gefahren als der krieg ausbrach dann
richtung kiew und haben dann zwei monate
dort in kiel verbracht und stündlich und
täglich gab es die anrufe panische
anrufe auch von diplomaten die gesagt
haben ihr müsst jetzt sofort verlassen
weil russland innerhalb von 72 stunden
dort sieht man auch bilder von meinem
gesprächen dort unter anderem mit
weselsky während der zeit des krieges
das ist der platz dort von wo wir
berichtet haben mit vitali klitschko
aber was ich sagen wollte ist dass es
diese warnung gab und alle fest davon
überzeugt waren dass kia fallen würde
also erst hat man gesagt man darf keine
waffen liefern und puccini zu
provozieren dann hat man gesagt man darf
keine waffen liefern weil die ukraine in
jedem fall verlieren wird und jetzt sagt
man naja aber im osten da wird man schon
gewinnen er steht da muss man nicht
sagen dass eigentlich alle experten in
ihren analysen und auch politiker falsch
lagen ich bin kein bild der experte ich
kann nur sagen dies in der tat haben
sich die dinge geändert viele haben sich
getäuscht das sagt ja trotzdem noch
nichts darüber aus und so hatten fand
ich das eben sehr besonnen was hier
gesagt worden ist dass man wüsste wie
die andere seite reagiert und sie haben
über uns gesagt scholz habe das schon im
atomkrieg
interview habe davon geredet habe erst
mit den gleichen argumenten schwerer
waffen was immer das sei verweigert um
sie dann zu machen auch das ist nicht
richtig sollen entschuldigung auch dass
es nicht wenn vieles wird behaupten was
nicht stimmt dass merkel ja herr stark
wie die listen ich habe mich jetzt auch
stehen aber der moment afrikas
geben wo er vor dem lesungen korrigieren
olaf scholz hat gesagt wenn ich das
sagen darf deutschland handelt gemeinsam
mit den verbündeten insbesondere in
washington und in paris macht keine
alleingänge das heißt ja wir sportler
fahren machen dies das oder jenes das
können wir nicht tun wir haben auch
manche von der ukraine nicht erfüllt zum
beispiel flugverbotszone zu machen weil
das die nato involviert ist wäre nicht
verantwortbar gewesen dass es keine
verantwortbare hilfe und ich gebe dazu
habe das nie daran nägel draus gemacht
ich mir schwer tue damit dass die waffen
liefern ich kann das bis zum gewissen
grad nachvollziehen weil die ukraine
sich dafür selbst verteidigen können
muss aber dass man nicht sagt wir
liefern jetzt einfach eine schwere und
immer schwerer waffen nacheinander
sondern dass man das abwägt unser fall
für fall abwägen gemeinsam mit den
verbündeten das ist eben der unterschied
zu herrn merz der markt zwar nach kiew
reisen wunderbar aber der hat nicht die
verantwortung der kann sich auch
täuschen in seiner einschätzung die
leute müssen sie verlassen können dass
der kanzler den sie gewählt haben nicht
nur der ukraine so gut hilft wieder kann
gemeinsam mit den verbündeten und
deutschland viel mehr als behauptet wird
wird dafür auch noch beschimpft was ich
eigentlich finde ich wenn ich mir die
listen angucken die ich einsehen darf
als abgeordneter sind hier regelmäßig
anders als das was öffentlich darüber
berichtet möchten sie uns gerne
herrschte krank ist das ist geheim
frankreich gesagt du bist gar nichts
darüber was sie liefern aus guten
konnten und wird dafür gar nicht
kritisieren ich will damit nur sagen die
besonnenheit dass man hilft so gut man
kann aber nicht in jedes mitarbeiters
moment so und nicht immer nur schaffen
aber helfen wirklich so gut wie wir
können was wir gehört war die gebhard
sind immer noch nicht geliefert es gibt
keine munition
das problem ist momentan im don was dass
die ukraine dort eben im osten massiv
unter druck gerät und nicht in die
offensive kommt und dadurch dass man
immer nur ein bisschen liefert und eben
nicht mehr liefert bedeutet das ja auch
dass ein krieg in diesem fall ja einen
gewissen stillstand erreicht sozusagen
und beide parteien sich bekriegen aber
keine von beiden parteien gewinnen kann
herr ernst sehen wir uns erst mal einig
dass wir die dass wir uns nicht in
diesen krieg involviert lassen nein
allerdings sind sich einig sie würden
gerne dass die nato mit einem nein ich
bin dazu ich bin der meinung dass
deutschland viel früher und entschieden
waffen hätte liefern müssen genauso wie
weitere staaten um dafür zu sorgen dass
russland zurückgeschlagen wird das
sozusagen der angriff der russen in
aller ob ebene vereint wird eine anzahl
polizisten die nato kann den
nato-angriff das sieht man schon mal
einig aber sie wollen mehr waffen sie
wollen noch mehr waffen und sagen hätten
sie schon früher liefern soll wenn wir
jetzt noch mehr waffen liefern dann
bedeutet durch das im ergebnis dass wir
ein ziel verfolgen das bedeuten würde
dass sie der auffassung sind russland
muss diesen krieg verliert natürlich aus
russland als jahre russland andere sagen
russland mit verlaub aber wer ein
fremdes land über ja ja ja ja ob und
dort was ich kenne die asienreise aber
häufig hingerichtet man ja gerade auch
nicht für solche andere nehmen dann muss
ja auch noch genug sagen was wäre denn
tatsächlich wenn russland den krieg
verlieren wird es gibt tolle analytische
die sorgenvollen estrich russland darf
den krieg nicht verlieren also erstmal
und will ihnen darf in irgendwelche
verlieren ich stets vielleicht mit einem
vernünftigen position halten dann wenn
dies eine vernünftige position ist komme
ich zu dem gedanken lassen wir uns doch
mal über lösung fänden verhandlungen
auch einfach aufgehört hätten sich auch
leicht zu lösende möglichkeit nachher
denkt er vielleicht von szenario wäre
nicht plant unheimlicher ist dann nur
noch ein kleiner als üblich und möglich
unterscheiden entscheiden nicht für die
ukraine ist ein selbstständiger staat
wir haben auch keine vorschläge zu
machen die ich sage nur aber dieses
genommen und zu den waffen der punkt ist
aber amerikanische präsident hat es
bestätigt anders als ein
verteidigungsminister vor das ziel ist
es die ukraine den krieg nicht verliert
und russland ihn nicht gewählt verstehen
das ist das den satz unterschreiben die
ukraine muss diesen krieg gewinnen ich
würde den satz unterscheiden die ukraine
dafür kriegt nicht viel kosten darf ihn
nicht gewinnen das ist mein satz uknb
warf ihn nicht verlieren darf ich nicht
gewinnen also sie würden den satz nicht
unterschreiben die ukraine muss diesen
krieg gewinnen ich glaube dass das nach
allem was ich von militärexperten höre
ich bin keiner ich fühlte dass noch mal
hin zu schwer ist zu behaupten man könne
einen krieg gegen eine nuklearmacht
gewinnen nächste punkt verlieren darf
man sich nicht wir können nicht zulassen
nicht dass man das telefonieren das ist
ja schon die falsche vorstellung und ich
leuchte nicht ich möchte nicht dass ein
diktat frieden gibt ich möchte nicht das
ganze nur verschoben werden auf das neue
ein paar es ist ja schon passiert da
merkt doch keiner sein ich möchte dass
ich möchte dass der für seine
kriegsverbrechen verurteilt wird all das
will ich auch und wir sollen der ukraine
bestmöglich helfen aber die vorstellung
man könne die russland betrachten die
zweitgrößte atommacht das haben wir
verstanden
ist auch verständlich muss es bedeuten
würde wenn das so wäre er anders als sie
vom vom gedanken ja wusste das bedeutet
dass ein kleines land soweit aufgerüstet
wird vermessen das ist eine atom auch
sie halten können sie also heißt wir
haben im bereich ist mit zehn millionen
einwohnern für ein kleines land und
somit eines der flächengröße
das jahrbuch der fakt ja und die
atomwaffen der ukraine wurden 94 gegen
sicherheitsgarantien unter anderem der
russen abgegeben hat ja diese nutzen und
sie heute ja das ist aber dass sie jetzt
sind wir in der jetzigen situation was
heißt ist wollen sie dass dort
tatsächlich soweit die ukraine aufrüsten
wie es die ukraine russland besiegt hat
ist das jahr bis die russischen truppen
aus der ukraine verscheucht und das
bedeutet auch die grimm im endeffekt
glaube ich nicht dass die krim momentan
realistisch ist ich glaube dass real
hatte was wir tun könnten wir doch schon
eine lösung lehrer die schon einen plan
ja ich mache was sie uns mit uns machen
also ich glaube ja
gehalten holz der diskussionsteilnehmer
hier ja dafür ernst in einer zukünftigen
leben dann wahrscheinlich auch
fernsehmoderator wird und dann wird dann
gehen sie gemeinsam morgen zu einer
talkshow internet im neuen deutschland
sieht an einlagen aber
aber ich glaube wir ernst hat am meisten
erfolg wenn er das in moskau macht also
werden sie dich unterschreibe den sieht
den satz unterschreiben die ukraine muss
diesen krieg gewinnen ja also ich halte
es mit annalena baerbock die hat gesagt
der russland muss aus der ukraine
verschwinden erst dann kann dieser krieg
zu ende geführt werden und kann ein
jugendlicher friedensvertrag geben und
das ist nicht unter kanzler dede
außenministerin nicht nur von mir
sondern auch von unserer bundeskanzler
unglaublich toll dass das dem
widerspricht niemand ich sie müssen aber
ich finde man muss fairerweise auch
genau zuhören wenn man sagt die ukraine
darf den krieg nicht verlieren heißt das
auch für deutsch gesagt putin muss
zentrum zurückziehen und aus der ukraine
verschwinden das ist die übersetzung
dieses satzes
sieg dann wenn ich sage russland den
krieg nicht gewinnen dann meine ich
damit da darf jetzt nicht mehr
zentralismus erfolg haben grenzen
verschieden und frieden waren das ist
die übersetzung nur wenn man sagt die
ukraine muss den krieg gewinnen oder
rosa muss ihn verlieren dann sind wir
auch in den bereich von dem die vorhin
gesprochen haben was machen wir denn
wenn tatsächlich eine taktische
atomwaffen eingesetzt wird irgendwo
wartet man zu sehen die ecke getrieben
ist und das immerhin mit zu bedenken
dafür zu sorgen dass das nicht geschieht
nicht nur über waffen zu sehen sondern
auch über diplomatie über
wirtschaftsfragen über humanitäre hilfen
über all die dinge die auch notwendig
sind zu reden das ist der teil den der
bundeskanzler verträgt und nebenbei
merkel daher hat auch die grünen und die
fdp in der bundesregierung dass man sich
nämlich einig in der bundesregierung
gemacht sehr viel klarer als ihre partei
das wissen wir auch dass es schon so
früh
natürlich hätte robert habe und an den
inder berbalk gerne früher
aber sieg und aber in der
bundesregierung ist man sich durchaus
einig sie sind dort neuerdings
militärexperte oder ich mach mich hat
nein ich bin kein experte multi ähnlich
wie rund und wir möchten die frage ob
die ukraine diesen krieg gerade wirklich
gewinnt und ob dieses land krieg
gewinnen kann das klären wir unter
anderem mit unserer militärexperten nach
der werbung